The EMF Harmonizer Pendant Necklace supports your health and well-being as you're exposed to the pervasive electromagnetic radiation in today's world.
While driving, shopping, or traveling in your home, office, or school, you will meet with EMF's emitted by many sources, from your phone, from Wi-Fi routers, from cell phone towers, and more.
The EMF Harmonizer Pendant Necklace will support your body against the negative health effects of all these EMFs.
It is effective for 5G, Wi-Fi, and all forms of electromagnetic radiation that you will encounter.
The Pendant Necklace is a stylish accessory, attractive enough to wear at work or out at night, but comfortable enough to wear during any activity.
It is made of durable and water-resistant stainless steel, and is easy to clean.
On the bottom of the Pendant are embedded four energy elements with added energetic support for the body's health.
EMF Harmony products are based on a bio-energetic technology from Europe that is applied in our workshop in the foothills of the Alps.
In development and use for over 20 years, our technology is proven and documented in research studies.
If you are looking for versatile EMF protection, the EMF Harmonizer Pendant Necklace is a powerful and affordable solution to support your health in the presence of EMF radiation.